- Getting into a consulting firm,
like McKinsey, BCG, or Bain,
is considered a quite
ambitious career goal
for many people.
So once you're in,
why the heck would you decide
to quit, to move out again?
This is exactly the topic
I want to talk about today.
Welcome to another Coffee Break,
here on my channel Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich.
I'm a former strategy consultant,
and I want to help you
to become successful
in the first years of your career.
So let's talk about
leaving a consulting firm,
like McKinsey.
And the inspiration for this
is a video that I saw on the
channel of miss Angie Lu.
She is a rather new YouTuber
who's creating videos
about consulting-related topics as well.
And here's one video
about why did I choose
to leave McKinsey?
You see that it got already 10,000 views,
which is quite a lot for
a channel of this size.
So I do like many of the videos.
I encourage you to give her some love
by subscribing to our channel,
if you enjoy this content as well.
So my plan for today is
to react to this video.
It's already skip forward to the part
where she starts talking
about leaving McKinsey,
what her reasons were.
And I want to look into this with you,
and give you my commentary on her points,
whether I think they are valid,
whether I had experiences
similar like this this as well.
So without further ado, let's get into it.
- Now, to be honest, why not?
Why is consulting, or McKinsey,
not the right career for me?
Well, first of all, I knew that
the lifestyle isn't for me,
the simplest way to find
out, is the future me test.
So if you are wondering the same,
just take a look at the
leadership in your same company.
Do you want to be like that leader?
Do you admire or enjoy the lifestyle
that he or she currently has?
As for me, yes,
the consultant lifestyle was
glamorous to a certain point.
However, whenever I look at
the partners at McKinsey,
their lifestyle,
I knew deeply that that was not
the life that I had in mind.
- I think that's very valid right?
Thinking about the next best
people in the hierarchy,
or your leads, your team leads,
the leads of your team leads,
what does their life look like?
What is their career looking like?
And is this something
that you aspire to do?
And here, I think it's understandable,
if you look at the partners,
how late they work, how busy they are,
how stressed they often are,
and you think for yourself,
and decide for yourself
, this is not a career for you.
The thing that's also fair to recognize,
that even though maybe you
don't want to become a partner
in a consulting firm,
just starting in coinciding,
and working there for a couple of years,
still might be a great choice.
The truth probably is that
only a very small minority
of all the people who joined consulting,
already decide for themselves that yes,
they want to pursue this career,
until they become partner.
It's rather common for people to say,
I just want to do this job for
two, or three, or four years
for all the learnings.
And then at some point
I can still reevaluate,
whether I do actually like it indeed,
whether I do want to continue,
or whether I want to move out.
- I do not want to travel
to different cities
every other day.
I do not want to have
to work until 2:00 AM
every single day.
I also did not want to
be away from my family
for most of the week.
- I think this is also very valid.
I made another video
talking about what the typical work week
of a consultant looks like.
I will link somewhere above here.
She talks about working until
2:00 AM every single day.
My experience was not like that,
that needed to work until
2:00 AM every single day.
But there surely were individual projects,
where working until 2:00
AM on a regular basis,
wouldn't be rare, right?
So you need to be ready that
things like this happen.
And yes,
you might need to work
significantly after midnight,
not all the time, but at
least on selected days.
And sometimes also for several
weeks on certain projects.
- Now second, the constant
pressure and urgency.
As you may know,
consultant projects are typically short,
and very challenging.
And most likely than not,
the team is always understaffed.
That's probably how consulting companies
make such a high margin per project.
- Yeah.
So she says a Panasonic
correctly that she believes
the pressure is so high, because
the teams are understaffed.
Not sure I would a hundred
percent agree with that.
So, I mean, we just talked about that.
Yes, there is a lot of work,
lots of things, lots of hours
that you need to put in.
But I don't necessarily agree
that just only if you would have one,
or two, or three additional
people staffed on the team,
that this would necessarily
make everyone's life easier.
So in a, like an MBB environment,
if we work for a consulting
firm, like BCG or Bain,
a typical team size would
be two to five people,
including a project lead.
So the team sizes are quite small.
I would argue that the main reason
why hours can be sometimes quite long,
is that just during the regular work day,
so from 9:00 AM to 6:00 PM or so,
you usually spend so
much time with a client,
conducting interviews, talking to them,
looking at some data that you get,
that you just don't really have time
to then synthesize all these insights,
to really create your documents,
do the actual work that you need to do
to really make progress on the project,
which is why this is often
what you end up doing
after 6:00 PM in the evening,
once the clients are not
in the office anymore.
- So, therefore everything
becomes a priority.
There were so many nights
where I would remember the
E.M., engagement manager
would say to me that this is a priority,
that you must finish before tomorrow.
So that's why typically we
work 12 to 15 hour days,
or even more.
And for me as example,
I actually have experienced panic attacks.
- Yeah.
So let's talk about that.
With everything becoming a priority.
So yes, for sure this does happen.
So someone pushing you to, in the evening,
maybe even at night, complete
something for the next day.
I did make the experience, those that,
especially in the first years,
it's like after one or two years,
once you've learned the job a little bit,
like earned your ropes,
you start also learning a little bit,
this game of pushing
back in the right way,
as a young consultant, as an associate.
I think if you're quite junior
in your first half year,
in your first year,
you feel like you need to do everything
that you're being asked to do, right?
Everything just say yes, of course,
I need to do the sense of what,
even though this means
really working really late.
There are some tips and
tricks, and techniques,
that you just pick up
over time to manage this
in a bit better way for you.
If you're interested in
learn more about that,
just let me know in the comments.
I might create some additional
videos on this very topic.
- Where I remember one weekend,
I was actually flying back to the project,
and as the plane was touching down,
I just get more and more nervous.,
where I could not even
hear the sound of my Gmail.
I kid you not.
I literally had to delete the Gmail app,
in order for myself to actually calm down.
The third piece is that.
- So this thing of panic attacks,
really feeling intense pressure,
really not being able
to handle it anymore.
I mean, yeah surely, you
know, people are different,
people react to stress in a different way.
I would consider myself probably
quite resistant to stress,
but even myself, I really
had also very, very,
let's say dark days or dark weeks, right,
in these situations in consulting.
I mean, I very well remember
being on one project,
I just felt under so much pressure,
my head was about to explode,
that's at least how I felt like,
that I locked myself into
a toilet cabin right,
at one of the client's places.
And I remember having a
meditation app on my phone.
So put on some headphones.
And I was just trying to
listen to this meditation app
for like 15 minutes or so,
just to calm down a little bit,
because it just couldn't bear it anymore.
I mean, the pressure can be intense.
Also here, overtime.
This is an area where you will just
need to learn some techniques
on how to handle that,
and how to also dissociate
yourself to some extent,
to really to work that's
going on the whole day.
But I mean,
these are things that can be
like a very significant burden
on some people, depending on
how you react to these things.
- Exhausting, from constant
travel and overworking.
If you were asking me back then,
what did you do on the weekend?
I will probably tell you, sleep.
I was sleeping until 11,
wake up for a quick lunch,
and then keep sleeping or take a nap,
so then I can recover
from the previous week,
and have enough energy for the week after.
I also remember that I hated,
hated, hated Monday morning.
Yes, I know Mondays are really hard,
but it's even harder when you
have to wake up at 4:00 AM
every Monday morning to
catch the first flight out.
Also you're working until midnight
pretty much every day of
the week, and because.
- I mean, this is
probably just true, right,
especially for these large
strategy consulting firms,
BCG, Bain, and so on.
I mean, you will just
need to work quite late.
You will often have these
weekends where you just sleep
because you need to recover from the week.
And frankly, I think
Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday,
are probably the hardest days,
at least in the, you know,
pre public health crisis situation
where you just were
traveling all the time,
because Monday morning, indeed,
as the lady just told us,
we wake up often 4:00 AM, 5:00
AM, to get to the airport,
get the first flight out.
Then Monday evening, Tuesday
evening, Wednesday evening,
is going to be quite late hours.
Then on Thursday evening,
you might fly back.
This day is already a little bit lighter,
because then usually at eight, 9:00 PM,
you will be at home and then some emails,
but not that significant work anymore,
at least most of the days.
And then Friday,
usually you will be out of the
office at 5:00 PM or 6:00 PM.
So nothing too crazy.
But there are many people
will need some time
to recover on the weekends, indeed.
- With all of this,
I actually developed the skill
to be able to fall asleep
or work, anytime and anywhere.
Back of the car, easy.
On the plane, no problem.
On the stairs, no challenge at all.
Standing in line, yeah, I got that too.
- Yeah, it's also true. Right?
You really just develop this habit
of just working all the time.
And to some extent,
I always wondered whether
this will sort of also like
just the group pressure.
Everyone else was doing it,
so you felt you needed to do it as well.
But on the other hand, it surely
was also part of, you know,
everything that you
could get done earlier,
just wasn't more time you had
in the evening for yourself
potentially to sleep,
so this is just what you did.
I remember riding a cab
once, being in a taxi once,
with a couple of other team colleagues,
and then the cab driver was asking us,
"So you guys must be from
this consulting firm, right?"
We just looked at us and like, why?
Like, how do you know, how
do you come up with this?
And then the cab driver was saying,
"Well, you guys from this firm,
"you're the only ones who
always open your laptops
"in the cab and just continue working."
- And I really want it
more hands-on experience.
Yes consulting companies will tell you
that they do implementation work as well,
but typically that's not
true implementation work.
We still stay very high-level,
and very strategic,
but it's also due to
the nature of our work.
Typically it is unlikely for
you to staff a consultant
for, you know, years to be able
to finish the implementation project.
But I really craved that
hands on experience.
I really, really, really
wanted it to be able
to build something on my own,
something that I can be proud of.
And I thought that that
the best way to do that,
is to leave consulting, enjoying startups.
- I mean, to some extent,
I think it's the right.
It depends also of course,
which specific conducting firm your join.
Some are heavy on the strategy side.
Some are more heavy on
the implementation side.
But also in a strategy consulting firm,
I did work on several
projects which were close,
very close to impact.
I mean, a good example, I think,
is always procurement contracting,
In procurement consulting,
you really often just work with the client
up until the point
where you really realize certain savings
with your suppliers,
indirect, and direct material.
So depends a bit on the type of project.
But of course,
for sure what you will
not do as a consultant,
is to take operative responsibility.
- And last but not least,
to be out of the bubble.
Consultants always have the reputation
of being the smart one,
but also the arrogant and
the self-centered one.
I'm not saying that everyone
in consulting is like that,
but I did find myself
for a period of time,
I was a little bit like that,
and I felt that I lost
my humility for awhile.
Well, it is because of environment.
- So here I'd say, I cannot really agree.
I really cannot say that
consultants were self-centered,
or arrogant, or anything like that.
So I met so many, extremely humble people
while working in coinciding.
They were just so kind so
friendly, so empathetic.
Surely as in most of these environments,
they're always are also
people that are not so nice,
or not so great,
people who I do not really
enjoy hanging out with.
But not to say that
consultants in general,
are so arrogant, and so on.
That at least in my humble experience,
this is not what I saw there.
- Wherein, everyone around us,
are prioritizing us, our
work over everything else.
Everything that we do becomes a priority.
I mean, think about the
glamorous lifestyle, right?
We literally had a team,
to book cars, and tickets,
and flights for us.
So I was constantly living in this bubble,
a bubble that has a
reality distortion field,
a bubble that actually separates
us from the real world.
- Here, I agree.
I mean, these support teams surely exists,
and this is, though, I would argue,
not just all of arrogance,
but just out of necessity.
So really just to be able
to just reschedule flights
all the time.
I mean, almost every Friday we took,
especially on Thursday, got
rescheduled at least once.
That was super common.
Sometimes you would even reschedule it
after the plane already departed, right?
I mean then it's probably a
question of personal character,
whether you let this get to you,
get into your head too much or not.
- It makes us oblivious,
and self-centered,
and arrogant pricks that we used to hate.
I really need to get out,
before it's too late.
Well, this is my story.
If you're interested in
exploring a career in consulting,
I hope my story can give
you a more holistic picture
of what's a career.
- Yeah, I think that
these were the points.
I mean, I provided my commentary.
I would of course be interested,
what do you think about that,
whether this matches your
experience in consulting or not?
Also just to be not misunderstood,
my commentary was not
about any specific firm,
or some, necessarily, of
any of my past employers,
but just my general
understanding of what it's like
to work in consulting, and other firms.
While some of these things
really sounded dark,
and maybe not so nice.
I still believe that consulting
is one of the best career choices
for aspiring young business graduates.
I made plenty of videos
on this topic as well.
I just do think it is
important, of course,
to be aware of what you're
getting yourself into,
because these are realities
that you will face
in many of these consulting firms,
and it would just not be fair
to not know about these things,
when you would decide to start
your career in consulting,
If you took any value
out of this video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm,
subscribe and all support
on the notifications
to stay informed on all
the videos that I create.
My name is Heinrich.
I release new videos
every single Saturday.
Big, big thanks to all the
members of this channel
for supporting.
I will link some videos
left and right to me
where you can continue
your learning journey
on this channel.
Looking forward to talk to you soon again.
Bye bye, Heinrich here.